the doctor strange story is a great cast
of characters chief among them is Carl
immortal well it certainly is the intro
to Doctor Strange entering this universe
moro is very close with the ancient one
played by Tilda Swinton she deals in
magic in real proper inner magic
together both the ancient one and moto
they sort of begin his training there
are other ways to save lives so much you
don't know
we're excited about villains in this
film we call them the zealots these are
people who become seduced by what they
find on the other side Casillas is part
of this temple if the majority is
looking for the truth here he's looking
over there for the truth he is
interested in spilling the barriers
between these dimensions
hey youtubers is charlie new Doctor
Strange trailer just showing off the
villains of the movie way more important
than the heroes so let's break it down
the thing I like about this movie is the
way they're selling it on the villains
like it's all about the rise of Doctor
Strange to sorcerer supreme but it's
more of a villains movie with Doctor
Strange in it like we're seeing this all
from dr. Strange's perspective but the
biggest characters are the villains
starting with Baron Mordo so most of you
have some idea for him in the comics so
let's start with him in the thing that
they're not talking about is actually
the most important thing that he's one
of dr. Strange's biggest villains but as
they talk about him in this movie it's
before he's fall into darkness but he's
still very close with the ancient one
helping her fight against kuselias like
the real villain of the movie played by
mads mikkelsen in helping this new
person who the ancient one says is very
important to learn about the ways of
magic so you can kind of see this
Shakespearean loki thor metaphor were
like the old favorite son meets the new
adopted son and grows to think that the
mother loves the adopted son more than
him so they don't really address that in
the trailer but it'll probably be in the
subtext to the movie and they'll follow
up on like it'll be a jumping off point
for future sequels so Baron Mordo not
going to be the main villain of this
film but could totally rise to be the
villain of a future film in a low-key
type way I think Loki is a lot more
playful than Baron Mordo the vibe that
I'm getting from Chi hotel I g4s Baron
Mordo is someone who is just like
utterly committed to their cause just
utterly serious but who has a small
sense of humor is that funny line in the
trailer where he gives him the Wi-Fi
password we're not savages so he does
have a sense of humor but he does look
utterly severe and you know how those
kinds of people like you've ever played
like a board game with somebody who
takes it way more seriously than all
your other friends they get really
pissed off when they feel like people
weren't taking it seriously so you can
see how he has to teach him the ways of
magic and is going to get really
impatient within his doctor Strange's
destined to become sorcerer supreme and
out match him that is really going to
piss him off but usually will you find
like when people like Loki and Thor come
to blows it's because of some
ideological difference so just put that
in the back of your mind it's not going
to be the most important thing in this
film the most important thing is just
watching Doctor Strange become Doctor
Strange in them learning about the
multiverse which is what they're talking
about when they talk about all these
the dimensions so Kevin pipes up
and he's like we are really excited
about the villains in this movie in mass
mickelson is like well you know
everybody's looking for truth over here
I'm over here in this other place
looking for truth so conceptually you
could say that his character feels like
our universe like our reality is just
complete and there's so much
more beyond and he wants to make it all
one like he wants to merge all the
dimensions of the trailer says which is
how you get to stuff like shuma gorath
Dormammu the Dark Dimension all these
other places with cosmic beings that are
just way Trippier than anything we've
ever seen in the movies before so that
is the back door to those things
appearing in the movie like they've
teased it in the Thor movies so far will
learn about hella who rules over as
guards version of hell so there's like
all these other dimensions all these
other universes Doctor Strange is going
to be the introduction to that but the
other important thing that I talked
about if you remember I made a Thor
video the other day about Thor Doctor
Strange crossover Loki is a magic user
he probably knows about all these things
the Doctor Strange is learning about
about the different dimensions about the
multiverse so while dr. strange is the
next movie it'll give you like the deep
dive like here is this wider world that
you didn't know about in the Marvel
Universe like he goes way beyond the
stuff that you've seen it gets way
Trippier and things are way scarier like
the Avengers are badass but how can they
stand against something like Dormammu
without the power of magic Scarlet Witch
has magic too but they haven't really
explained how powerful she is it's
related to the mind gem so when we get
to a finity war we will have team magic
moments like Doctor Strange interacting
with Loki is marvel team magic so just
expect that same type of scene with
Doctor Strange and Scarlet Witch
eventually too but if anything this is
really like the first big Marvel movie
to flirt with the horror genre there
have been like horrific things happening
in the other Marvel movies but this is
the closest to being classic horror like
giant tentacle monsters from another
dimension the devil of the Marvel
Universe so you can see they're pushing
into new genres but let me know in the
comments what do you think the
post-credits scene is going to be at the
end of this do you think it'll be some
sort of Avengers infinity war teaser do
you think it's going to tease guardians
the galaxy vol 2 because that will be
the next Marvel movie and sometimes
there's some connective tissue between
those two things but I feel like it's
mostly connected to the Thor film so
there might be a hat tip for that they
just hired dan harmon to punch up the
script they're adding a few scenes to
the movie like they're doing reshoots so
they're just like tweaking things before
it's actually released so I just love
the idea of crazy Rick and Morty
going on in the Marvel Universe
hopefully Dan Harmon will Cronenberg the
out of the film just because we
have like the really light fun Marvel
movies you want to have the spectrum you
want to have like the deep psychological
horror Marvel movies you want to have
the Buddy roadtrip movie that's the Thor
film you want to have the big team up
those are the Avengers films so they're
just like all kinds of different genres
represented in the Marvel movies but
giveaway time if you guys didn't know
there's been a giveaway going on Emerson
Fleming you went a thirty dollar amazon
card is basically for the value of the
captain america civil war blu-ray which
is dropping this friday so I'll totally
do a new video for the deleted scenes
like all the stuff they left out of the
movie if there's anything cool so I'll
reboot the giveaway now all you have to
do to enter is be a subscriber and leave
a comment on this video I'll be doing
the Marvel giveaway in all my Marvel
videos this week so no worries plenty of
opportunities to win a copy of the DVD
but there's actually a rumor going
around the captain america in Black
Widow will also guest star in spider-man
home coming along with iron man so I'll
probably do a video for that next
there's also some Deathstroke Justice
League that I want to do so either one
of those videos of posting X but a whole
bunch of Marvel and DC coming this week
where you guys wait for that to post you
can click here for that funny thor
ragnarok trailer again and you can click
here for spider-man homecoming behind
the scenes thank you so much for
watching everybody let's high five I'll
see you guys tonight
you